[Musique]
dans la grisaille qui enveloppe les
minarets des mosquées d'istanbul se
réveille un bateau navigue
tranquillement sur le bosphore entre
l'europe et l'asie les pêcheurs de
sardines du pont galata sont déjà à
l'oeuvre c'est un matin d'hiver comme
tant d'autres dans la métropole turque
[Musique]
de byzance à constantinople puis à
istanbul la moderne la ville est une des
plus fascinantes de la planète mais pour
la grande majorité de ces 16 millions
d'habitants la richesse dans les rues et
les bâtiments témoigne surtout du passé
et de moins en moins du présent
ce jour-là denver dans un des plus
anciens bazar de la ville les
stambouliotes sont nombreux à venir
faire leurs emplettes
ces marchés publics sont moins chers que
les épiceries mais même le bazar est
devenu cher avant on pouvait acheter
tout ce qu'on avait besoin avec 100
livres turques maintenant c'est
impossible
devant ce comptoir d'olive on croise mur
at borhane propriétaire d'un restaurant
ces dépenses ont explosé dans la
dernière année
à deux pas de là ismaël lô nook vend des
sous vêtements pour femmes on pouvait
lui en acheter 4 pour 10 livres turques
il y a quelques mois aujourd'hui c'est
le double
ma femme et moi sommes retraités mais
pour arriver on doit être ici et vendre
on n'a presque plus de vie sociale
on achète moins de vêtements en coupe
partout entre eux
selon les chiffres officiels l'inflation
sur un an dur qui vient d'atteindre 50
4% en février c'est dix fois plus qu'au
canada des études indépendantes conclut
même à une inflation qui surpasse 100%
autrement dit la vie est devenue deux
fois plus cher en un an c'est dans l'est
du pays les plus élevés au monde c'est
un risque pour la turquie murat chapman
est un économiste indépendant réputé au
pays la cause de l'inflation vient d'une
part de l'extérieur parce qu'on a une
inflation mondiale et aussi parce que
nous avons commencé à baisser nos taux
directeur de la banque centrale mais
pourquoi les autorités ont fait baisser
ses taux alors que pour lutter contre
l'inflation
les experts s'entendent pour dire qu'il
faut les monter c'est bien sûr contraire
aux théories économiques il y a un but
ça a été dévalué la livre turque pour
être plus compétitive
sauf que la livre turque a perdu 60% de
sa valeur en cinq mois face au dollar
une catastrophe pour un pays
importateurs comme la turquie est un
choc énorme sur le pouvoir d'achat des
turcs dont le salaire moyen ne dépasse
pas dix mille dollars par année le
président redjep tayyip erdogan n'en est
pas resté là en deux ans pour un
directeur qui ont été congédiés bien sûr
ça
augmenter les risques voilà c'est
la turquie a besoin de stabilité
économique au sein de la population la
frustration monte face au président qui
est au pouvoir depuis 19 ans avec les
salaires on ne peut pas payer les loyers
il ya plein difficulté j'ai peur qu'il
va y avoir une j'espère que non une
émeute tôt donc c'est parce que les gens
ils en marche jusque là dans ce décor
tout ce qu'il ya de plus officiel nous
avons été reçus par un proche du
président ado and akif chatte iclic est
député à istanbul pour la cape et le
parti au pouvoir depuis 20 ans
[Musique]
qui a fait mal à l'économie turque dit
il ce sont les hausses du prix de
l'énergie l'instabilité au proche orient
et le manque de touristes liés à la
coved et non pas la baisse des taux
d'intérêt
pour aider la population le président r
douanes a augmenté de presque 50 % le
salaire minimum en décembre dernier ce
qui veut donc dire qu'aujourd'hui une
majorité de turcs gagne environ 4000 250
livres turques par mois mais c'est à
peine l'équivalent de 5000 dollars
canadiens par année c'est nettement
insuffisant
considérant que l'inflation elles
augmentent encore plus vite
dans la partie asiatique d'istanbul
nous rencontrons la famille mais tin
soner et libraires et inde et sa femme
travaille en relation publique
il y a dix ans je vous aurais dit qu'on
était dans la classe moyenne mais
maintenant l'écart est énorme nous
fonçons vers la pauvreté et l'on ne sait
pas ce qui va nous arriver
sans critiquer son gouvernement elle
s'inquiète pour l'avenir de sa fille et
du bébé qu'elle attend dé plus en plus
nous perdons espoir dans l'avenir de
notre pays nos racines nos traditions
sont ici on veut que nos enfants
puissent y grandir et y être heureux et
guého goons voudrait lui aussi être
heureux et croire en son avenir
il a 22 ans et travaille à temps plein
dans un café au salaire minimum il a
arrêté l'école pour subvenir à ses
besoins
et j'ai fait partie de ceux qu'on
surnomme la jeunesse erdo and see turc
qui n'ont pas connu d'autres dirigeants
et pour qui entendre que la turquie a
déjà connu pire ne console pas fier pour
faute d'argent il n'a jamais pu voyager
mais sur les réseaux sociaux il constate
à quel point d'autres européens ont une
meilleure vie
travaux
mais il le sait d'autres jeunes à
quelques centaines de kilomètres de chez
lui sont encore plus malchanceux
aujourd'hui la guerre en ukraine risque
fort d'aggraver la crise économique
turque le pays s'attendait à une saison
touristique record cet été la majorité
du tourisme vient des pays russie
d'ukraine et caetera et c'est pour ça
c'est cesser importance y est pour nous
nous avons beaucoup d'importation
exportation avec la russie murat de
salman conclu sur une note positive le
pays habitué aux crises a l'habitude de
se relever rapidement les 86 millions de
turcs veulent croire croire en une vie
meilleure avec assez d'argent pour ou
moins rêver